hey everybody welcome back to parkitect
today we have to tackle robo park the
description of which states that we have
to build a state-of-the-art amusement
park featuring expensive high-tech rides
and roller coasters on an empty
peninsula that has previously been used
as a research facility
now there are quite a few scenario goals
we have to have 600 guests
no loan debts an overall park rating of
at least 80 and 1500 in terms of monthly
profit from rides
which seems like a lot but honestly
given the fact that this map is not too
difficult to work with
i think it'll be fine now before i get
into building i just want to quickly
mention
that a new update for parkitect update
1.6 has come out and at the same time a
new dlc as well called booms and blooms
and i don't want to go
into this in depth or advertise it
specifically because i want to spend all
of my time trying to finish these
scenarios as quickly as possible
finally i should add but there is some
really exciting stuff that i want to
point out and also some things that i
want to note first of all the free
update mostly adds
bug fixes and some minor new features
but it also adds some really interesting
scenery for instance we have more basic
shapes now
which will be super useful in building
all kinds of buildings you could
definitely go much more in depth
with particularly themes like sci-fi i
think so it'll be interesting today to
see what else you can do with these new
pieces
there are some other smaller new pieces
as well i think there are some
frame pieces in the wall section for
instance there we go that'll be super
useful for certain types of coasters or
uh technical buildings and then there
are some other new stuff as well
but i also have to say i already have
the
dlc as well the booms and blooms dlc
which adds not quite as much stuff as
the taste of adventure dlc
but still a lot of new scenery and some
new features
it comes with three new roller coasters
a few new flat rides
firework shows and also a sequencer for
these which
feels very similar to roller coaster
tycoon 3
and also loads and loads of trees
which i guess this is where the blooms
part of the name comes from and then the
booms is of course the new fireworks
feature
but all of these beautiful new trees are
part of the dlc
and not part of the free updates of the
game therefore i want to try not to use
them in the scenario so that my
base scenario play won't be
misrepresenting what the game is
actually like
but i will have to try my hardest
honestly to stop myself from using these
trees because
they do look like you can do so much
with them and foliage in this game is
just gonna look
so much cooler and more interesting than
it has been looking so far
anyway with that all out of the way i'll
link some
links to the 1.6 update overview as well
as the booms and blooms dlc in the
description below
and yeah let's just get started and
finally build robopark
alright so starting off here i'm doing
something which i usually like to do at
the start of a scenario and just build a
quick
entrance area and the first building
mostly just
as a test to see what pieces i can use
and what color combinations work
together
i think these first kind of buildings
for me at least always work as a proof
of concept just to get used to the new
theme and try to
work your way into it and discover some
of the tricks and the pieces and
everything that you can use in the rest
of the park
to make it all feel like a cohesive
whole another thing that i want to
quickly mention is that i always look at
what people are doing with the scenarios
partly because i made quite a few of
them and i'm just interested to see
what people like and dislike about it
but also because i think that's what
makes you better at a game
and what just helps you get ideas and
ways to work with the pieces in the game
i always get questions about how i get
inspiration
for the things that i build or how i get
good at games like this
and i think a lot of it is just watching
what other people are doing
seeing what their methods are what they
end up making how they use the pieces
and try to learn from that and i think
it's also the one way that
uh communities like this are really
interesting is that
it's very cooperative everybody just
brings in their own
ideas and even if you're not a super
experienced player you can just
mess around in the game and see what you
can do with the pieces
and if you post your stuff you never
know like other people might get some
ideas
uh for things for themselves with the
things that you do and i think in this
sense
communities like this really lift each
other up
everybody is inspired by each other and
in parkitect over the past couple of
months i've honestly just seen this
community get better at this game
i think i've personally improved a
little bit compared to some of my first
scenario plays but honestly not as much
as i'd like to
especially looking at some of what other
people are building nowadays
it's absolutely amazing and it's just
really cool to see a community
collectively get better at this game and
build really cool stuff and on the topic
of robo park specifically
i was really intimidated almost
by some builds by studio kv and
astrotron
who i think really have this sci-fi
theme down much better than i do
honestly sci-fi has never been my strong
suit
definitely not in parkitect i would say
but their stuff is
really cool so for one i was kind of
intimidated by it but at the same time i
wanted to try and go into a slightly
different direction
so my inspiration for this build
actually came not just from looking what
other people are doing with park attack
sci-fi stuff
but looking up lego sets and things that
people have built
in lego in in some kind of sci-fi or
industrial theme
and trying to see what kind of things i
can bring
in with the the park attacks pieces from
that
and i found a lot of towers especially
towers and spires with round roofs
and rings to create a sort of strange
alien landscape and i think
that's the kind of thing i want to try
and go for for this build
to avoid making this scenario into the
the pipe landscapes that i've seen
on some of the other tries in robo park
and i'm still drawing some inspiration
of course um especially these
overhanging roofs on this building that
i'm
doing right now for instance i've seen
quite a few people do
in sci-fi and park attacks they work
really well
with basic shape pillars which you can
see on the building as well
so these kinds of early art deco
modernist inspired designs i think also
work really well with this theme
but especially later on in the scenario
i'm gonna try to make things a bit more
outlandish
and work with those towers and weird
round ufo is
shapes to make something a little bit
more unique
and when i
also i should definitely mention that
i'm trying to see
wherever i can use some of the new
pieces from the free update of the game
and it's not that much because the
pieces are kind of basic
and even though they are very widely
applicable it might be hard to catch
them if you don't explicitly know which
pieces i'm placing where
but i think there's some decent examples
here so for instance on the overhanging
roof
on the building that i'm currently
working on those cross braces
are some of the new roof pieces i'm also
using them on the building right next to
the entrance
and i think some of the new basic shapes
can be super useful for pipes
and things like that which i will get
into
in just about 10 minutes in this time
lapse i think
but it's really cool to see how you can
use those pieces for
very generic basic kind of things where
you almost don't really notice that
you're using new pieces but at the same
time they're essential to the thing that
you're building
but yeah this building itself is kind of
inspired by
art deco like streamlined modern things
with lots of classical ish elements but
then
very sci-fi stuff um so this building
structure wise you can
also see it's almost like a classical
building with a large awning on the
ground floor
what with the the pillars and even the
kind of
monster roof which is a little bit
parisian almost
and then a corner piece with a dome on
top of it which you'll often find with
classical or art deco buildings as well
but then just the actual detailing and
the colors and everything is a lot more
sci-fi
honestly i think another way to get
inspiration can
really be to try and replicate the
structures of a certain type of
architecture but use them with
completely different detailing or color
to create something new so for this for
instance even if you're building
something futuristic
i don't think there's any issue with
going back in time and trying to get
inspiration from other building styles
and copying at least the the sort of
general
composition of the buildings and then
applying new detailing and colors
because sometimes you can get some
really cool stuff i think this
especially works in the steampunk theme
for instance
which of course is a kind of victorian
imagining of the future
but i think it can be applied to almost
any theme really to try
and create some really unique new ideas
now right here i'm moving to another
building
i honestly don't have an exact idea of
what
each of these buildings are but they are
kind of strategically placed i should
say
because this scenario is one of those
kind of annoying scenarios that starts
you off with very limited shops
the only thing i have for food is a
vending machine
and while that will do for the beginning
of the scenario at least
i'm really gonna have to upgrade and see
if i can find some
food and drink stalls because otherwise
people are gonna be super annoyed
and this was kind of one of the
challenges with this park that i
didn't really remember or think about
when i
looked at the map and i looked at the
objectives and thought oh this is going
to be easy
but there are definitely some more
hidden challenges to
to overcome as well and the lack of
shops
despite the importance of shops is
definitely going to be one of those
i think another thing that makes this
scenario interesting
is as a sort of thematic through line i
wanted to make sure that everything you
have in the scenario is
somewhat futuristic so as we get into
the flat rights and the roller coasters
later on in this build
you'll be able to tell that everything
is kind of futuristic and sort of
late game rides one of the things that i
always liked about roller coaster tycoon
for instance
is that you always start off with very
basic rides the slide the carousel
things like that and then you only get
the more high-tech rides later on in the
game and later on in the scenarios like
the top spin
and the freefall tower so when you got
those flat rides it always felt like
you were getting out there like you were
achieving some kind of success in the
game and you were really reaching the
later stages of the game
and i was trying to harken back to that
a little bit with this scenario and get
some of the most complex and rare flat
rides
into the selection for this scenario so
most of the stuff that
you only find in some of the later
scenarios
or that takes research to unlock in the
earlier
scenarios all of that stuff you get
straight away from the get-go in this
one
and you don't really get any of the more
basic flat rides so for instance we
start off with this
ridiculous flat ride which by the way
honestly in
in real life these things are really fun
um
they kind of are a little bit
uncomfortable but they're not nearly as
nauseating as they look
um but yeah super fun flat ride but kind
of one of those more high-tech rides and
the same goes for
most of the flat rides and the roller
coasters in this scenario in general
now speaking of roller coasters i ended
up
choosing to build a polar coaster in the
middle of the park
and because i was being super impatient
i didn't want to try and build some more
easily money making rights in the
meantime
so here we go we dive straight into the
polar coaster now making the layout for
this thing was a mess
and a very terrible process that i ended
up skipping
but it's going to be interesting to give
this thing a theme
i think because the idea of a polar
coaster is
that you have a large tower of some sort
a roller coaster that goes from the
bottom to the top
and then has a layout winding down the
sides of the tower
i think the the concept was popularized
by a proposal to build a polar coaster
tower in las vegas
a few years ago which looked absolutely
nuts it would have been the tallest
roller coaster in the world
but then it never ended up getting built
i
don't know if it's ever gonna be built
in the in at all
or if there's ever gonna be a polar
coaster in general in the world
but the concept is really cool and i
figured it was worth a try
fun fact i actually tried making a polar
coaster
park for one of the scenarios of the
base game and
create a sort of flat plateau on top of
the tower where you could build your
your theme park and try to force people
to build everything off the ground
it never ended up becoming a scenario
for the base game because it was just
way too annoying to work with
because uh camera wise it's it's a bit
annoying and it's also very difficult to
make a layout
for a polar coaster that makes sense on
the small scale of parkitect
but for this scenario i really wanted to
try and revisit the idea and make a
proper polar coaster this time around
so the way it works is um we have a
tower very much just inspired by
television towers like the ones that you
find in many cities around the world
just a bit more sci-fi-ish and in the
middle
of that tower we have the vertical lift
hill going straight up
for a while i was actually thinking that
i would have to
um get the euro fighter coaster in
research
in order to build this polar coaster but
turns out that the
hydraulic launch coaster also has a
vertical uh lift hill which i think
makes sense
i'm i believe it's probably based on
fahrenheit in hershey park
which is a roller coaster with a very
similar track and train design
which has a vertical lift hill as well
but whatever the case i uh
i could already built this coaster
because this coaster actually comes with
the scenario as you open it
so it's just about the perfect coaster
type for the thing that i'm trying to do
here as well
and then on top of the whole polar
elements i'm adding the
uh sort of the the viewing platform
which
unfortunately cannot be a real viewing
platform because there's no way to get
people up there with the roller coaster
in the middle of the tower already
but still i felt like for the look of
this tower
this would look really cool and also you
can see some of the round
spires and domes that i've placed on
some of the other buildings already
with this tower i'm trying to create the
the one spire
and and dome ish ufo shape tower that
would rule them all
uh so this is kind of the thing that
sets the theme for the rest of the park
and definitely if you want to hear me
say this word again
it's definitely the weenie of the park
as well which is cool
i haven't built too many weenies in
architects i think
but out of everything i could build i
feel like this would be one of the most
fitting weenies
for a robo park especially also
big f for the rocket like
launching platform that was in here
before originally if you open this park
there's like a some kind of rocket
installation
on this this part of the map as a sort
of pre-built weenie for the park
but honestly i thought that was a little
bit too lame and something like this
would be a lot cooler
also another thing that i want to note
is that
obviously right now the layout of the
polar coaster is a little bit lame you
just come out of the vertical lift hill
and then you go into the right hand turn
down into a dive drop if you will which
is that twist followed by a half loop
and then it's really just the helixes
all the way down you first start with a
kind of slanted
helix which brings you up and down in an
overbank
and then you go into that double helix
on the bottom because it was
really tough to fit in anything else
down there that wouldn't be too
fast also usually polar coasters have
brake
runs everywhere but this polar coaster
has a very long terrain so i figured
that wouldn't really work because you
need a long enough brake run
that the train can stand on it and
there's no way to find
space alongside this building here um so
it's just helixes
all the way down and then you go
straight into break run at the end which
i'll admit is very lame but that's not
gonna be there permanently
that's honestly just because i'm running
out of budget if you look down in the
bottom left you can see that there's
barely any money left and you start out
the scenario with 25 000
i blew most of that on completely
unnecessary scenery and a ridiculous
over the top roller coaster already
so from a gameplay perspective i don't
think it would be very smart
to try and get a loan to finish the
layout of this coaster
so what i'm doing is i'm first finishing
off this this polar section of it
and just putting the basic scenery
around that and
once it starts making money hopefully
because if it doesn't i'm absolutely
screwed i have no idea what i can do
but once it starts making money then i'm
just gonna
you know expand the layout at some point
in the future
figure out how it can fit in with the
rest of the park i'll deal with all of
that stuff later
i do like the idea of building a coaster
you know as
a basic concept first and then expanding
on the layout
if you get the money if it turns out to
be popular enough
i don't think that's ever been done in
real life it's rare to fight coasters
that have been
changed or extended based on their
original track
i know i'm getting very off topic but
it's it's interesting to note that it's
something that you can do in games like
this but it doesn't really happen in
real life i think the only
example that really works
is a powder keg which i believe is in
silver dollar
city it could also be in dollywood no
but i think it's in silver dollar city
but it's a it's an old flume ride
which was destroyed quite a few years
ago
and they kept much of the original track
in place
and then added to it a launch section
and a whole new section of track and i
believe it's
by sns now um so it has an air launched
section as well
but yeah it's it's fun to see a coaster
that room that keeps some of its
original track and then expands on it
with new elements as well but it's rare
to see it in real life
either way that's what i'm planning to
do with this thing later on
also interesting to note i'm building
some supports on this coaster and i'm
using the new
basic shapes for that and really i think
these shapes
allow you to do basic steel coaster
supports completely custom
in the game the only downside to it is
of course that these pieces are very
small so as you can see i need to place
many of them to even create support
structures
but with the with the basic cylindrical
pieces that we have and then also the
round flat pieces
you can build steel supports including
flanges
and use the square basic shapes as
footers as well so you can make some
really realistic supports with this and
the benefits of these
over the cornices which some people use
the supports before
is that these pieces are actually round
so they kind of look
like coaster supports and also you can
place them anywhere on the grid
and i kind of had to get used to this
but i'm using pieces the size of 0.18
which means that if you're building
straight pieces and you're on
a four grid so you're dividing the grid
into the four grid spaces
each by pressing alt f4 you can
perfectly connect them
and another good thing to keep in mind
is that if you're building diagonally
you can use a six grid to perfectly
connect these pieces
and if you're building slanted so uh
kind of diagonally up and down
uh you can use a eight grid i believe
would be the best option to build
uh pieces like this like the thing that
i'm building right now
all together it takes a little bit of
figuring stuff out and it takes a lot of
building pieces to make these supports
but ultimately
you can make custom supports in the game
and this has never been possible before
at least not without mods so that's
really cool
especially for me because you know if
you really want to play the game modded
there are some really good custom
support mods as well
but because i want to play the scenarios
without any mods
to prevent any cheating or making
anything that wouldn't be possible in
the base game
um it's really good to have these basic
pieces and be able to actually add some
extra scenery to the roller coasters
so yeah obviously all of these supports
are hooked up to the tower
of the um polar coaster itself so that
there's a very clean look to the tower
in general and everything is just
suspended from
the big concrete beams in the middle
with of course the exception that the
final turn which edges
too close to the ground to really use
the tower for support still
but all together i think it looks really
cool
it even kind of looks like a rocket or
some kind of space thing i don't know
there's a very spacey look to the tower
and especially with the fins going out
to the side like that to provide extra
support from the side
it looks a little bit rockety so i i do
like the look of this thing in general
i'm just not really sure how i'm gonna
be able to
actually pull in the rest of the park to
make it fit with this look as well
but we'll try and see how that works
anyway
for now let's take a quick look at how
the coaster works
alright so here we are this is the final
results as the car creeps down the dive
drop here and you can see it going into
that helix
losing some speed not going that quickly
as it goes up and down this helix here
but then
finally it drops into this large helix
where it slowly builds up more and more
speed and momentum and then
it's it's all gone it's dead at the end
super anticlimactic
i know it's terrible but at some point
in the future my plan is to expand this
into an airtime hill flying over the
path here
and into an inversion and have some kind
of cool interaction with the scenery
here
definitely need to leave some space open
so i'm also not going to do too much
with this ride otherwise
i just really need to make some money
right now speaking of which
i am making some money so that's kind of
good for a few months now i've been
making a very
humble profits now i don't think i'll be
able to
keep doing that for that much longer so
at this point
i'm honestly starting to get a bit
impatient and i think my next plan is
just to get another loan
um just get a small loan going and build
some more rights
the only annoyance at the moment is that
um
i switched the research to roller
coasters slightly too late so even
though i have fruit juices now
and i also got hamburgers so that'll be
quite nice i'm planning to build
a food court inside this building which
is now called the the weyland
corporation but
i guess uh i guess it works um but yeah
once we get that first eight room out of
the way i definitely want to see if i
can get another roller coaster
in because right now my only other
roller coaster type is the
mouse and god knows i've been building
too many of those and they're
just not quite as interesting to play
with thematically or
layout wise than coasters like this for
instance
anyway i'm pretty happy with how it's
turning out so far
so let's jump back into the time-lapse
and see what else we can make of it
alright now i'm starting out here with a
big water feature and i want to say
straight off the bat i did not come up
with the idea for what i'm about to do
here
but unfortunately i don't know who did
because i saw a fountain posted on the
park attack discord
quite a long time ago i don't even
remember exactly when i just
remember the build of somebody taking a
bunch of fountains and putting them
together to make a big water feature and
i thought it was really cool
where i personally always just stuck the
regular
water jets on water and use that but the
idea to use the real fountain pieces
as a way to make something that's kind
of part sculpture part fountain
especially in this ridiculous sci-fi
sort of theme
i think that's really cool and i wish i
could credit this to the original poster
i
just can't for the life of me remember
who it was and
i tried to dig back into the discord but
i couldn't find it anywhere so if you're
watching this video just on the off
chance you are
um leave me a comment and i'll see if i
can pin it and thank you for that
on that note though i do want to say
that i think with games like this
everything just kind of revolves on
everybody in the community getting
inspiration from each other and
drawing from other people's builds and i
think no matter what skill level you're
on
it just helps to to post your stuff not
just to get
feedback for yourself and some
constructive criticism maybe
but also for other people to see it and
get some ideas from that i think
everybody gets better at games like this
gradually as
people figure out new tricks and new
ways to work with scenery pieces
color schemes etc and for parchitects
especially for me it's been so much fun
to watch in the past couple years
uh the general skill level of people has
gone up
and at this point i just already kind of
feel almost
like i'm i'm i'm out of place in here
because some people are making
really amazing creations in this game
and
well i have the platform to show it off
to a large audience
but i still kind of struggle with the
question of you know what you see me
building
isn't 100 my own work obviously i build
everything
and i go out of my way not to steal
anything from anybody else
but it's still a product that's a result
of me
being just one of the many players of
this game and
giving back and and taking from the
community just like anybody else does
with a creative game like this
but yeah i think that's that's how it is
um and there's not much we could change
but then i think it's also a really
great thing for games like this and it
doesn't really go for parchitect alone i
think you really see it with
city skylines and planet coaster as well
with any of these kinds of creative
games
the builds just get better and better as
the game gets older i think
so yeah that's all just to say people
have been doing such amazing stuff in
this game
and also i need to add that i probably
should have done an update video about
the newest dlc in the game
um because ideally i would feature
some scenarios maybe or do a showcase
video um or just anything
to show what exactly the the new
features of the game are because they
are
really great but i just don't really
have the opportunity and i can't really
show it here in this scenario but there
are a few other things which i think are
noteworthy
one of them is that you can rescoe rocks
now so you can actually make very small
pebbles which seems like a very small
addition into the game but i think it's
really great for the nitty-gritty
detailing
and there are even rescalable bushes in
the game at this point so the amount of
items that you can just make bigger and
smaller
uh is getting is getting bigger as well
um and just
everything in the new update is
recolorable and it just adds so much
depth to what you can do
with all of the new pieces one thing
which i kind of skimmed over
but is pretty well relevant i guess
is that there's a new ground texture as
well there's a soil texture now so for
any planters
or any kind of forest or whatever
kind of greenery you're looking for i
think that's a really great ground
texture that can actually make a
difference in some builds
and it's something i don't really get to
use in this episode and i
certainly don't think i'll be using it
much in the next one
it's still something that i think
especially if you're trying to build
realistic parks or playing the game in
sandbox
can make just all the difference in in
how you make your greenery
anyway to get back to what i'm actually
building here i decided to add one more
building on the side here
my idea for this park at this point was
to make the entrance area kind of the
quote-unquote sci-fi main street so this
is where most of the buildings are going
to be and this is where i'll keep most
of the facilities
but quickly i realized that i would not
be able to
keep up this level of detail and
intricate scenery for
the entire map and also i think it
wouldn't really work
at some point i think there's just too
much detail on too many of the
same looking buildings that it doesn't
really matter anymore how much you add
so i'm keeping most of the dense urban
landscape just here
at the entrance section and then the
back half of the park towards the end
of the peninsula there is going to be
more foliage
and a much bigger focus on roller
coasters as well
and i guess at this point i can also
note that
this is officially now the longest
scenario
in all of my playthroughs of architects
so to everybody who's watching this and
wondering why it took me so long to
bring out this episode
it's been recorded over the course of
weeks to be honest
and i've just been chipping away at this
thing but it's been so much work and
not even everything has made it to the
time left so i did cut out
the kind of arduous process of actually
making the roller coaster layout as well
so yeah all in all it's been a beast of
an episode and by far the biggest
so far at least in terms of how much
work i've put into it
so i'm sorry that it's taken this long
to get here
um but it's it's also over an hour of
video so
i hope you'll excuse me also perhaps
you'll be watching this back
in segments if you're even watching the
whole video because i i think i'm
definitely pushing it here in terms of
video length for youtube
it seems kind of ridiculous to upload an
hour of a let's play
of a video game at a time i just don't
want to split up these videos into
different episodes i just want to have
every scenario being
neatly one episode so that's how we got
here to this point where you're just
watching an hour of time lapse which
honestly it's ridiculous i don't want it
to get to this point
but that's just what it is that's just
how robo park is and
it's a larger park than you realize
beforehand as well and i think i just
wanted to fill in the entire map
while not having to sacrifice any
detailing so
this is the situation you end up in at
that point
anyway i added another flat ride here as
you can see
we're still staying in the theme a very
high tech ride
i don't think you can even get a simple
ride in research on this map
i was researching the um the junior
rights for a while like the uh
the gentile rights and i just completely
forgot
that in the research tab i just left out
most of the the gentle right so you
don't really get anything i think you
get an observation
tower and two other rides but nothing
special
so most of the flat rides are also going
to be quite
on the thrilling scale i'd say but i
think that also works for the the theme
of the park
and they tend to be the flat rides that
just look more
technological and high-tech so i think
it just works like that
and then over here i just on on all of
the corners
of this this main street-ish area i
i just wanted to have these these big
weenie-like
towers with round ufo-ish domes
so on this corner that's this one and
then on the left you
you have the one that's next to the
water and then of course at the entrance
you have a few of them as well
and i think these all just add a very
simple
if kind of cliche sci-fi look to the
whole plaza
i think the fun bit of this was that
with every tower and dome
i could see what different pieces i
could use in
in various arrangements to to get a very
different look to each one of them
while at the same time it's a pretty
mindless job and you can just
do it all your way at it with different
scenery pieces and see how it turns out
this tower in particular i think is
really just a miniature version of the
big tower in the middle and i think
partly that goes for all of the towers
they are all very similar to the big
weenie in the middle of the park so i
think that also helps the park
to feel a bit more cohesive as well
anyway we're moving on to a different
part of this episode
and that is the flying coaster layout at
the end of this scenario i actually only
have two roller coasters but they're
both pretty intense and pretty expensive
and
quite special so honestly i'll take that
over
having a bunch of junior coasters and
wild mouse coasters in the park
and i think it also goes with the theme
that this park gives you in a sense that
everything is kind of high tech
and quite intense so i didn't want to
add in any simple and not so thrilling
roller coasters
and i think flying coasters in this game
especially are really fun because you
have this freedom
over exactly how the banking works so i
know i already moved on to different
places here
but i just wanted to comment very
quickly before i come back to the flying
coaster
how the banking flexibility of the game
really allows you to come up with some
crazy light to fly element or fly to lie
as they call them on flying coasters so
for instance on this layout
i built a corkscrew that is 90 degrees
tilted at the top of the corkscrew
and then at the back you tilt 90 degrees
again so the whole corkscrew is like a
big
light to fly element this was actually
inspired by roller coaster tycoon 3
where i found out that if you connect
two
over banked turns together which in the
game
are perfectly 90 degrees at the top you
can actually make them into a light to
fly element so this big corkscrew is
very similar
and i wish there was a flying coaster in
real life that did this because it just
seems like such a cool thing to
experience
i'm not entirely sure if it's safe in
terms of forces
maybe it's a bit intense you might get
some ejector airtime at the top of the
corkscrew or
very strong laterals but it just seems
like such a cool thing to do especially
because you're used to
corkscrews and dive loops i guess
tilting you 180 degrees as you go into
that curve so i feel like it would be a
really fun experience to only be
tilted 90 degrees on each side and then
just come out a completely different
orientation
as you come in i think it's also the
only part of the flying coaster which is
actually very unique because the rest of
the layout is fairly standard diving
coaster procedure
we have a quite shallow curved drop into
a pretzel loop
and then finally also an immelmann going
back
into the rest of the layout a few twists
and turns and then we get into the crazy
corkscrew element
and finally there's just a lie to fly
roll
back into the brake run i tried to leave
some space here so that i could fit in
the queue as well as
a transfer table which to this day
i still feel like it's fun to add these
for all the courses in parkitect i know
they're never functional
and it's maybe a bit too much detail for
just a simple scenario playthrough
but i don't know the coaster freak in me
just needs to see some of those small
touches of realism or it just kind of
breaks my immersion
and these things don't have to be too
detailed so i suppose it's all fine
i'm also sticking with the default
colors of the coaster in the game which
is just
those blue tracks because it just fits
with this park
everything is either purple or blue or
some shade of blueish green and there
are really only about
four or five different colors that i use
throughout the park
i actually go back and i think this is
off camera but i go back at the end to
slightly change it up because it is
very simple and it is a lot of the same
colors so add
just a few small warm accents at the end
with a lot of
orange little pieces on many of the
buildings
and also some accents on the flat rides
um but yeah most of the colors are just
those those blues and oranges
so we have one coaster which is this
dark blue so the other coaster is very
light blue to kind of contrast with that
but at the same time
stay within the same color and now it's
time to tackle the other coaster
which is also pretty fun because we get
to make a whole new layout for it
at this point i had ten thousand dollars
in the bank well
way more than ten thousand and i figured
it would be enough to finish the layout
of this coaster
but eventually i ended up adding so much
more to this that
i couldn't even afford that so i had to
play the game a little bit longer
just to get the funds for this but i
mean despite the fact that
these coasters are both super
inefficient because they're way too huge
and you don't really get much of a
monetary benefit from such big layouts
i think it's just what i wanted to have
in this park and
they still make enough money once
they're finished to actually
continue building on the park um but i
do like the
uh the approach to just build a partial
layout first
and then once you get enough funds
actually continue because for a while i
was
super afraid that i had to restart the
park
and i think this is something that
lingers at the back of my head for
basically every single episode i do
because you always have that part at the
start where you create the scenery and
the rides and everything but you just
needed to make profit otherwise you're
screwed um but yeah i think the tactic
of just building part of the roller
coaster instead worked
pretty well and i prefer it over
building you know profit based layouts
because
as much as i understand that i am
playing this game as a scenario and i
need to try and make money and reach the
goals and the challenges
i still hate building layouts that are
focused on making money
rather than than actually just being a
fun coaster layout
now i was also struggling for a while to
figure out exactly where i wanted the
coaster to go i think part of the reason
why
i struggled for it with a while um for a
while i mean
is that i wanted to have an mcbr at some
point i needed to have some book breaks
just to be able to run two trains at the
same time on this layout because i
figured otherwise it would just be way
too inefficient
i mean this is an absolutely monstrous
layout you first have that whole section
on the polar coaster and then you just
move into what is
basically a big intimate looper um but
in the end i just couldn't fit in a
mid-course brake run so i decided to
just leave it out
so instead we have this this other
immelmann element
turning into a cobra roll and then a
quick turnaround into a corkscrew and
then i
almost did a sort of interlocking
corkscrew there the way that b
m likes to do them as well but i figured
nah this is an intamin
realistically this this would definitely
be an intimate in real life as well
i mean it has to be i feel um and they
they'd be more likely i think to to
finish it off with another
airtime hill although that said
it is very similar to the um what do
they call it again the
the the element in maverick i've got the
name for it but i know there's a there's
an element in maverick that
kind of does this this interlocking
corkscrew action
but anyway uh those aren't exactly
interlocking so
it's not quite the same i just figured i
i like the layout most like this and
then it's it finally the end of the
layout is just a quick
s turn followed by another s turn doing
that kind of cheetah hunts
shenanigans and then we move into the
final break run
a fun sort of side effect i think of
this way too long layout
is that the trains end up stuck on the
lift hill and normally
i always change the timings of
the the station and maybe even the lift
hill speed to make sure that trains
don't get stuck but i think on this
coaster it actually is kind of a cool
feature
uh so what you get for most trains is
that they'll stall at the top of the
lift hill and they'll stand there for
10 or 20 seconds and people get to stare
out at the the outside world from the
top of the tower before they are finally
released and start moving down that
tower so
i think that's part of the fun really it
kind of gives you that almost
tower of terror like reveal of the park
and just a little bit of time for people
to process that and take in the view
before they
fall down that ridiculous layout by the
way i'm sorry if i voice crack there
i notice it's something that ends up
happening sometimes when
i talk a lot without any pauses
and yeah you'll have to excuse me for
how it's sometimes difficult to just
keep blabbering on and on without you
know having
a moment to think for yourself or your
voice to recover because
honestly at the end of videos like this
my mouth actually gets a little bit dry
and
sometimes you do get a little bit of a
sore throat
it's something i really only realize
when i'm recording stuff for youtube but
talking a lot
actually is pretty damaging to your
voice at least
temporarily i don't know any long-term
side effects but it's something that
surely kicks in
and i know these videos do get stupidly
long and
especially because i'm talking the whole
time sometimes it can get a little bit
long-winded i guess but
that's that's just how it is that's how
these videos end up being
and i don't really want to compromise on
that to be fair it
it started out like this because these
park tech videos used to be
around maybe 20 30 minutes and i just
started putting more and more effort
into them so i didn't want to split up
the videos and just keep the format the
same but they just keep getting longer
and longer
but at the same time i also just feel
like they're
i just kind of want to show off
everything i don't see a reason to cut
out any particular thing
you guys can just skip through the video
if you don't think it's interesting
and i think that's a fair um yeah a fair
way to do it
although if you're if you're listening
at this point and you want to give some
feedback just let me know if you
actually like me talking for hours on
end or if you prefer having more
short edited down videos or if you
actually just listen to these things
all the way down and have these on in
the background like a podcast or
something like that i have heard some
people
who do things like that as well anyway
just keep in mind that me using my voice
for an hour sometimes does get a little
bit difficult so
i do kind of dread especially these
longer time lapses as well
now i actually wanted to get back to the
building for a second because i haven't
talked about this building at all and
that's kind of a shame this is actually
my favorite building
in the scenario perhaps aside from the
central tower which i guess is really
the highlight obviously but i think this
is the point where you could
tell me getting better at the pieces and
more used to exactly how this theme
works
i think whenever you start a new
scenario you always have to figure out
what kind of pieces you get to use
and what color combinations etc at least
that's the case for me and as you keep
building you get more comfortable but
you also kind of get more bored with the
theme
and for me this station building was
just on that on the balance between that
where
i was still interested and still trying
out new stuff but at the same time i was
comfortable
with everything i'd done so far and i
knew exactly how i wanted to approach it
so we got a building that is pretty
unique in the scenario but still draws
elements from most of the other
buildings
with the round spire with those sci-fi
building pieces but then
all of the corners work on the square
parts the the square base of the tower
as well as the roof for the station
where we have that glass section with
the sort of framework on it and i don't
know i just
i just like how it turned out and i
think it has the colored accenting in
the right places as well
so i'm pretty happy with that building
overall
i also decided to add some quick screens
to the uh
the queue line um i say screens but i
really mean those
those i don't know exactly what they're
made out of actually but those
those shades on cue lines that you often
see in real life as well and they're so
simple to make
in this game with just some basic roof
pieces and pillars
but it's always something nice to add to
your queues and something realistic as
well that
especially in climates like this now i
don't think the climate in robo park
is too harsh looking on the bottom left
it's pretty temperate
and kind of northern european i guess i
don't think i had a particular
well location in mind when i was making
this scenario but it's not too bad
but yeah it's it's always good to think
of cover in your queue lines
not to mention that it's a thing in the
game as well that you need to think
about rain cover
and i know i always forget this
personally but your guests actually do
appreciate that stuff so that's good to
know as well
i also added some very simple terrain
underneath the coaster i didn't add the
new dirts
coverage just because i figured it would
look
too different and clash a bit with the
normal grass texture
so i'm still going with that kind of
brownish grass
i feel like this is something that's a
leftover of the roller coaster tycoon
three days honestly
i don't know if anybody has noticed but
i really like putting different textures
right underneath my coasters and this
really doesn't make sense
there's no reason for a different
texture to be there honestly there's not
a realistic reason that i do it anyway
i just know that back in roller coaster
in three days many people would put
kind of dirt or grass textures
underneath that coaster tracks and i
think it's just a simple way to spice up
the look of your build
because there certainly is no way that
grass can't grow underneath coaster
track
i just like the look of it and i'll
honestly admit it's it's nothing that
you have to do
it's just something that i like for for
variation but you can definitely also
add
terrain textures in different ways maybe
make some clusters of trees
and have muddy textures underneath that
which i think is a much more
realistic approach and definitely
something i do in many of my scenarios
as well
just in this case i figured it would be
interesting to do it this way
terrain textures i know were something
that i
forgot to work much with in some of the
earliest scenarios and i know i got some
comments about that so it's still
something that's
always in the back of my mind like hey
put down something and make sure the
grass isn't just all the same you know
it's a very simple and easy thing to do
in this game but it makes a huge
difference
if you're looking at everything from
above now speaking of rain coverage
we have some kettle pens going back and
forth here in the queue line
i didn't quite know what to do with the
roof i just knew i had to do something
different than what i've been doing
with the roof so far so i decided to
just slap
some flat frameworks on top of that and
have a little raised section
sometimes you honestly don't really have
to come up with a logical explanation
for things i know i like to do that a
lot and
even just with the terrain textures
right now try to reason myself into
any kind of realistic reason why i would
do something but
it's totally fine to do something just
because it looks cool and
i i try not to forget that either you
don't always have to
justify what you're doing exactly
so moving into this area i was
kind of procrastinating on this part
because i didn't quite
know what to do with this i knew i
didn't you know
want to continue the facade that i had
going of the buildings here because
we get to a section where we have a wall
behind this flat ride and i didn't think
it would be fitting to add
windows and a detailed building right
behind that when the focus should be on
the flat ride instead
but then i also didn't know what to do
with the space in between that because
we do still have a sort of two grid
space to fill up with the building here
so in the end i actually ended up going
back to some of my pictures i took in
japan
and looking at the buildings there and
figuring that for
a theme park that's a theme to robotics
and technology
i have a lack of japan inspired things
and while this facade here isn't super
inspired by japan it's still
kind of based on the very narrow
plastic-ish looking buildings with lots
of
technological details that you see
everywhere in japan
they don't like to decorate those
buildings a lot and
there's a very similar archetype that
you find
all over cities like tokyo and nagoya
and osaka
and i just wanted to kind of add a
building slightly inspired by that
if i had more time and if i redid
robo park i would actually love to do a
robo park where
all of the buildings are inspired by
that where you have all of these modern
narrow buildings standing in a row i
think it would be really cool
and actually an interesting way to add a
lot of diversity
in the buildings but yeah i this is a
this is my uh
robo park take where i never really
ended up focusing on that so
i'm just adding a few buildings here and
there that are kind of inspired by it
and then behind the flat ride i
i didn't really know what to do so i
just ended up putting a
empty wall there to cover up some
supposed backstage stuff where we have
the
drop-off points for whatever needs to be
delivered to the park
not sure how it's going to get delivered
because there's not a highway going into
the park here
but let's just imagine it's a sort of
real backstage area
but yeah we need some kind of wall to
cover all of this up
at the back of the flat right that also
kind of fits with the flat ride
so i just decided to build a a simple
decoration
that uses the same colors as the ride um
and yeah this is what i came up with
just a bunch of cubes on the wall
basically
it's not the greatest thing but i didn't
want to take focus away from the ride so
i think it works
decently at least as a way to give it a
basic backdrop
and then i wanted to cover up the queue
as well of course
gotta be careful here with not making
the flat right go through it because
scenery items like this don't have a
hitbox that's based on the flat ride
itself
so you can easily end up going through
it but i think the uh
the the clearance on this is fine so
i'll trust my judgement on that and
finally because this is a backstage
building and we do need those air vents
and little chimney pieces and those
kinds of details on the roof
i'm just adding some pipe work and
simple stuff out here i know astrotron
who's one of my favorite players of
parkitect
has been getting progressively more and
more detailed and intricate with his
rooftop hvac systems i've seen some
buildings in this game with just
hundreds of pipes going everywhere and
just a myriad of
boxes everywhere on buildings which
looks awesome
but honestly i wasn't really feeling
like it i just wanted to put down the
bare minimum
and continue to plopping down trees and
more buildings inside the park itself
but i'm still happy i did a sort of
basic backstage area because i felt it
was really the best way to
finish up that corner of the park and
really make clear that that is the the
sort of themed
disneyland tomorrowland kind of area of
the park and that the rest
just gets more intense and ride focused
and
has fewer buildings
but yeah we have to keep going there's
still a lot to do in this episode
and the first thing i wanted to do here
is finish
off this side of the plaza for a while i
wasn't sure if i wanted to build some
buildings here or what i wanted to do
in the end i opted to actually keep the
area around the tower mostly empty and
open
because i think this focus on the tower
itself is
much more important and if i would add a
building around here
i wanted it to actually be smaller um
from my
own perspective of maybe being a guest
and and looking
at this this park from a ground
perspective i think it would make sense
that the buildings around here would
actually be very low to the ground and
smaller in scale than the other
buildings to
create this forced perspective of the of
the big
tower that it's even bigger than it
already seems and of course i want to
keep the view of it
mostly uncontro unobstructed and
well unconstructed as well i guess that
makes sense
um so yeah we just have a small sort of
food stand-ish building here i'm not
exactly sure
what this building would be but yeah
maybe it could be a small snack shop or
something like that the funny
funny thing about this thing is actually
that this round outcrop on the building
that i just randomly came up with that i
think it would fit with all of the other
round towers in the park
i ended up repurposing that at some
point later in this episode
into a cover for q lines
which honestly i think it works pretty
well for it's like a big
technologically advanced umbrella
perhaps
so yeah you'll see that come back at
some point in the future but for now i
wanted to add some paths underneath the
flying coaster
for no reason other than the fact that
i just heard something outside don't
know what that is but yeah i added some
paths here
for no reason other than the fact that i
just wanted to have some interaction
between the coaster
and add a spot where people could take
awesome pictures of the coaster
i don't know how important this really
is but i always like to design some
specific photo points because when i
visit a theme park i do like to sit down
at a bench and just look at a coaster or
even take some pictures of it
i know i've definitely skipped out some
re-rides of coasters
just so i can stand outside with my
camera and i haven't even
made vlogs out of most of those pieces
of footage
because i don't know i just like looking
at coasters and taking pictures of it i
know what it is
don't hate me for this it's just it's
just something i like doing and
i want to accommodate that for people in
my parks as well right
and i guess the guests in the game also
kind of enjoy it
but really this this path doesn't really
go anywhere it's kind of useless the
only thing that i end up adding here
which i almost spoiled there when i
almost placed down the flat ride but
realize that i didn't have enough money
is um i add a uh a big top spin well
the the tourbillon at some point which
is just the crazy
high tech top spin so i think that only
makes sense given what kind of scenario
this is
so yeah here we go i'm saving the the
round
little pavilion and putting it over the
queue lines here
i know it looks like it's completely
under supported but well
you have to imagine that at the bottom
of these round things there's a big
fat pillar made out of basic shapes
which it really is there you just can't
see it because of the perspective of the
game
but all of these basically act as big
umbrellas
and they're a pretty fun way to add a
cover to this flat ride
they also carry the three main colors
for the park in general
for every building i just have to choose
one of those colors depending on what
colors the buildings around it already
have
and for these three i figured you know
what they might as well just have all of
the colors will make it a bit more
interesting
i also did try to add some variation in
the foliage depending on different areas
so the flying coaster gets the super
purple
cherry blossom trees which no other part
of the park gets
and then the intamin polar coaster gets
the white blobby trees
which also no no other part of the park
gets so you kind of get the
signature trees of the coasters if you
will and then the
the other pinkish trees and orange
maples
are kind of scattered throughout the
rest of the park to add some color to it
the funny thing is this whole deal is
reminding me a lot
of an old roller coaster tycoon 3
coaster that i was making
back in 2014 i imagine this was
maybe 2015 as well i know i was working
on it for a while and i never actually
ended up finishing it
but it's a coaster called protoss and
the idea was that it was
just traveling through a big
technological facility
on mars where
water is generated from things in the
air or whatever
it was i had this whole storyline for it
that i completely forgot but it was a
water-based facility in space and it had
a coaster going through it
and i still remember that all of the
buildings had had lots of pipes
and weird metal details and the main
color scheme for the ride
was basically exactly the same as the
color scheme for this park
so the whole time i've been building
this i've been
reminded of protoss in the back of my
head i still want to try and dig up that
save file i actually recently tried to
open it with all of my custom content
reinstalled in roller coaster gun 3
but it crashed upon opening it and i'm
not sure if i'll ever get it back to
work and
it's so sad because it's probably my
biggest project i ever did in
rollercoaster
3 just one of those things which it was
so big
that i never really finished it and i
could never release it completely
just just one of those things so that's
kind of a shame
but i still like it looking back at it
and this park
maybe still carries some of the energy
from protoss
i don't know if any of my old roller
coaster tycoon 3 viewers are watching
this video right now especially given
that
in my protoss days i didn't have many
viewers
but if you are watching this and you
remember that
you're an og and i just want to say i
love you
but that goes for everybody watching my
videos of course i wouldn't be nearly as
motivated
for for doing all of this and putting
all of this effort in
if it wasn't for all of the awesome
comments and
feedback i still get from everybody
whether that's
loving or just super critical and
at least constructively critical because
i do love to get those comments as well
because it helps me improve my videos
obviously i keep
saying that in way too many of my videos
i know but also don't
don't hold back if you're if you're
telling me anything could be completely
personal and subjective or something
that you think i could just
objectively improve on but i always like
to hear things i'm doing terribly
because otherwise i'll keep doing them
terribly of course
anyway that is uh that is it for the
tour beyond that's not it for the time
lapse yet i realize i said anyway kind
of in the cadence there as i usually do
at the end of my videos but no
we're we're not even over an hour into
this video this still has to continue
for a while i'm sorry
but yeah i just finished the the big
hyper cube
top spin thing and we have another
building there which uses a very similar
dome
as some of the entrance buildings and
this one actually kind of like as well
the detailing is a bit different on this
one but it's
i like it actually with the the with the
small pipes on the roof
as well as the arches and just the
general detailing of it
i think i've just gotten a little bit
better at this theme
than i was at the start of this scenario
and you can tell that the
maybe the the build or quality
difference
is is there if you compare the end of
this
this peninsula that i'm building on
compared to the start
but it is what it is i also have to say
that
i'm building kind of differently from
what i imagined when i made this
scenario but i think at this point
i made this scenario about two years ago
so
i'm also completely forgetting what kind
of mindset i was in when i was making
these maps
either way i just added some small
planters here in the middle of the paths
because we do have a lot of path space
with a few different textures um so i
wanted to at least break that up with a
few trees
and i know i didn't talk about the trees
much
i know i talked about the color trees
but the realistically colored trees
i wanted to feature a lot of square
trees because i think it
works with the scenario it's something
that of course the park came with as
well
and i want to continue that theme but i
do think it works with the sort of
technology focused
scenery that we have all around here and
it kind of reminds me
also of the topiaries well they're not
really topiaries but the
the foliage that you see in disneyland
paris around
the castle as well where you also have
these
shaved trees as well and i think the the
planters kind of reflect this as well
they have these same
square but kind of bubbly shapes and now
here
we finally get what i believe is
actually the last building
of this scenario might have to check
on that later but no i'm pretty sure
this is the last building so at this
point i was
pretty much done with building for this
park but i still wanted to add one more
thing because just having pots over here
with
nothing to look at or to do seemed like
it would be a bit too empty
and it would be a bit too obvious that i
just put these parts here as filler
so now one more building it is and this
one kind of has a round
outcrop with pillars underneath it to
create a small gallery
and then a strange roof where i'm still
not entirely sure what i was doing with
this roof or what i was thinking about
this
i just wanted to add something like this
i know in the
disaster peaks video i was talking about
art deco
and how i would love to still do some
art deco architecture
and for the longest time in the scenario
i've been thinking that
this might just be the scenario to do it
never ended up doing it
but at least i do see a tiny hint
of maybe streamlined modern as they say
in the round shapes of this building and
the horizontal stripes
it's something that at least seems to be
kind of outdated
futuristic theme if you get what i mean
and i think
this map has this in general nobody
looks at this and thinks oh this is
the future it it still has a bit of a
pastiche feeling to it for me where
it looks like the future as the past i
mentioned it
and i think tomorrowland is a good
example of that so
i think the the comparison with that is
pretty decent or as well but
it's it's definitely something that i
feel with this build
and yeah actually the last building
wasn't the last building because i still
built something here
so i completely forgot about that i left
this spot open the whole time because i
didn't really know what to do but we
kind of have this
the small harbour here and i figured it
would be one
more opportunity to add some slightly
japanese-ish looking buildings
those small narrow buildings that still
have a few floors
um and yeah at this point i really
wasn't sure
what to do with these anymore i did do
the same glass trick that i've been
doing for many of the buildings here
where i layer different panes of glass
to get a deep blue color and you don't
see it from every perspective but it
definitely makes a difference
so it helps you to to create these
glossy
focused buildings with big windows as
well um
and then we just have some random
stuff behind it because i i couldn't be
bothered at this point and i figured for
a small port
area this would be a realistic addition
just a bunch of clutter
and that finishes up this part of the
park and that's the scenario
so let's jump into a real-time section
and see what it looks like
alright so here we are here's the park
in its final state
and i guess it's funny that i just said
that i was done with it
and i'm kind of moving toward the end of
this episode but i just
realized that i'm not nearly making the
goals for this scenario
i do have almost 600 guests in the park
i mean 428
is kind of close at least two-thirds of
the way there
but i still don't even have a profit
from rise of at least a thousand five
hundred dollars
so i really hope that i'll be able to
make those goals with some campaigning
because otherwise i think i'm really
screwed
so we'll see exactly how much of a
difference some campaigns make because
i'm definitely stalling at this point
so let's just do a free ride voucher for
six months for
i guess the flying coaster i should do
and then we'll do
a uh attraction advertisement for not
the right that's for free of course
but on television we're gonna advertise
the poller coaster
that seems pretty important we're gonna
make an advertisement for the park for
six months too
on television i mean it's that's too
expensive
all right uh social media i guess maybe
it will spread out
all right park advertisement goes out we
need to advertise one of our shops as
well we'll advertise that on television
i suppose
and we'll select well what shop are we
gonna select
hamburgers seems like a good option and
we're gonna can we still do an
attraction advertisement i forgot if i
already did that
uh i guess we can still do the
transformer
yeah let's just go for it all right so
six months of that
we still have money left so let's do a
free park entrance voucher for
six months oh i can't do that because i
already have a campaign for a robo-park
all right
sure sounds good and i guess i can't
oh i can still do another advertisement
for
the drinks all right let's go for it all
right let's see the differences of those
advertisements hopefully i'll be back
with you guys soon to check on
the effects of that i have to say so far
i
mostly left all of the campaigning to
the end of my builds
and usually i've been able to make the
goals with that even if i didn't seem
close at the end
but for this one i'm really not sure so
i'm gonna fast forward for a bit and
i'll be back with you guys once
things are looking a little bit more
rosy see this is what the consumer
society does to the brains of these poor
old park tech people they just can't
help themselves
it's barely been two minutes and i'm
already over 500 people in the park
after plateauing and about 420 for a
while so
i think the effects are pretty clear the
only problem is
well there goes the stream of people
entering the park and it's not quite
enough yet
and i also just realized that i kind of
shot myself in the foot by giving out
free ride vouchers when i need to get a
thousand five hundred dollars
in rides profits so
i'm not sure how that's gonna go but
still i'm gonna look at the current
situation and
see if it's gonna improve and how close
we get to those goals with
really only a few flat rides and some
coasters
you know in hindsight maybe i haven't
done the best and
smartest approach to this park but we'll
see
okay i'm actually kind of confused now
because for a while i've been able to
break the minimum profits and i also
have 600 guests in the park
almost 700 even and i'm at almost 3 000
from profits from rides so
i'm actually not sure if there's one
thing which i forgot
oh it's my loan all right well that's
easy enough
let's get rid of that and oh god
three weeks to win we'll make that i'll
i'll see you guys at the end of that bar
alright
alright just a bit more there it goes
it's crawling to the end there
and there we go that's robo park
i mean i think i did pretty well
actually on that one
so i guess that's just to show you the
absolutely insane effects of campaigns
even if they are super expensive in this
game because a big campaign is about as
expensive as a big roller coaster as you
could see
24 000 just to advertise the park on
television
but at the same time it it has such a
huge
impact on how many people visit your
park and you can see it in the profits
as well i know i don't actually delve
into finances too much
in my playthroughs but if you go back to
earlier years
you could see i was averaging about just
over a thousand dollars in in right
income
um some months were pretty bad and i
assume that's
related to the weather or something or
just the coaster being closed or broken
at the time
but just these last couple of months
i've been pushing the the
three 2000 dollar range so that is quite
a difference and i don't think
i've really made back the money from the
the campaigns
it still costs money at the end of the
day it's not like
rollercoaster tycoon where i think
campaigns were absolutely broken and
just made your park work so much better
but they are a big boon when it comes to
actually making the goals of a scenario
that all said let's see if there is a
train stuck
at the top of the tower here not yet
um so we should be able to see it climb
up here soon
there we go it slows to uh to a grinding
halt there
and then the people get a few of uh well
quite an interesting view actually just
not quite over the park but at least
over the flying coaster area
and given that the facts given the fact
that this park is somewhere out at sea
i think you'd actually have a really
cool view of the water from there so
there we go and sort of a dive drop like
we're on a wing rider
and then into a big helix and really
this whole polar coaster section is just
one giant helix i don't even know quite
how many degrees this is but it
definitely goes around maybe four times
or so
picks up a lot of speed and then it
launches straight into the zero g
roll here over the paths and i think you
get a good view of that if you're a
guest on a walking somewhere on those
paths
into another inversion and a turn and
then a cobra raw
i don't know what it is but cobra rules
just always seem to work so well on
intermittent coasters
they just look really cool um i think
colossus for instance is a really cool
looking cobra role all of the 10
inversion coasters of course do but
colossus is the first one and then we go
into this corkscrew here
quick turnaround into a twisted sort of
airtime hill
always love those things and then a
quick as bend
snake sort of movement and then back
into the station where we have the brake
run and also the transfer track of
course
not super detailed but i always think a
small realism detail like that adds a
lot to a ride
and of course we have the flying coaster
as well perfect timing
thank you very much and we have a
nice curved drop down here it's actually
not very tall it's not a
very big coaster to be honest the
pretzel look just only
barely fits with the in-game elements
so yeah here we go pretzel loop named
pretzel of course because it's shaped
like one
and then here we go into what's actually
a sidewinder i guess because we have a
half loop followed by a corkscrew here
some twists and turns through the
pretzel loop which i think is a nice
quick bit of interaction
as well with the parts and then we have
this kind of strange corkscrew element
and i still wish a flying coaster in
real life did this it seemed like uh
like such a cool addition and i think
you get some nice forces when you're
on your back as well during moments like
this and especially in a pretzel loop
you have some really insane forces on
these coasters
because for some reason your body just
doesn't handle g-forces as well when
you're turned on your back or at least
they just seem a lot more intense so for
anybody who hasn't been on a flying
coaster with a pretzel loop
those things are absolutely insane one
of my favorite roller coaster elements
for sure
really intense personally i've been on
the one in tatsu
and the one in flying dinosaur and i
think tatsu has the slightly more
intense
uh pretzel loop but flying dinosaur is
just
more intense overall and has some really
insane lying elements
anyway that's it for a robo park
let's just quickly spin around the main
tower i found that there is a particular
perspective where
you can keep the tower in exactly the
middle of your screen but i always find
it difficult to
find exactly where that place is on the
map but it is fun to kind of rotate
around it and see the whole park from
different perspectives
more than usually i think i tried
building this park from different
perspectives as well
and i think it came out nicely i think
it's also worth pointing out some of the
additional color details that i added so
for instance we have the
orange pillars here and some warm colors
in here as well i think actually this
purple goes very well with this orange
definitely something to remember lots of
little orange bits here too
and of course that color also comes back
in the flat right here
so all together not everything is quite
the same color but i think you can tell
you can still tell that the the park
overall still has a very distinct color
scheme to it
so yeah that's it two big roller
coasters
a tool a transformer here a
top scan and also this crazy g-lock ride
i don't actually know what those things
are called in real life but they're
great fun
and of course also the the double
inverted swing
so not too many rides but even with that
you can
make a break for uh the goals of the
scenario but i think i really just have
to give the campaign
the most credits here because if it
weren't for that i'd only have about
half of the people in my park
and definitely not the monthly profits
that i need to have
anyway let's get out of here this
episode has been long enough i'm
actually just gonna
um well no i'll still save it actually
um
but i'll see myself out and
let's see what we get actually as a
trophy for this park but i can already
guess that it's going to be the the
rockets
thing whatever it's actually called
whatever the the rocket launches from
and after that we just get a quick path
to
oh we get another path to zalgonia
that's interesting i wasn't actually
expecting that
but yeah here we have zelgonia which is
gonna be uh
the last scenario in parkitect don't
worry it's not gonna be the last
scenario of this playthrough
because i'm still gonna play the dlc of
a taste of adventure
but it's gonna be the last of the base
game hopefully it doesn't take me as
long to make this episode as robo park
did
hopefully also the episode is gonna be a
bit shorter but um
we'll see it come out in due time anyway
i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and i'll see you in the next one